what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time well while
she's trying to get rich the rest of us
just trying to get our lunch money right
i'm here with pelina
she's great she has on a georgia
sweatshirt though which is not great go
gators but don't forget now that lunch
money is sponsored by block five block
five has three products you can buy and
sell crypto you can deposit crypto and
take out a us dollar loan against your
crypto collateral
or you can use my favorite product as an
investor as a user
is an interest-bearing account you can
earn up to 8.6 apy
in that interest bearing account you
can't get those types of rates in the
traditional world so go check it out 8.6
apy in an interest-bearing account go to
blockfly.com pomp and check it out
what's up all right so this is
ridiculous
it says that almost nine million people
who still haven't received their 1200
stimulus checks
can expect to get them in the coming
weeks that includes individuals and
families who don't typically file
tax returns because their incomes are
too low
and those it's just ironic because those
are probably the people that need the
stimulus checks the most
and they're the ones that we can't get
it to so why is the irs sending them a
message
because they oh you can tell that you
could still get it so there's nine
million americans that could still get
the check
because yeah wow and it's typically
because their incomes are so low they
don't
file with the irs so the irs doesn't
have their information it's like three
percent of americans
it's pretty crazy yeah i didn't know
that but it's just isn't it ironic
though that people
who need it the most cannot get it
that's how the financial system works
right
is the bank banks is the best example
the top four banks made eight billion
dollars off overdraft fees last year so
literally they took eight billion
dollars from people who didn't have the
money how does that work
right same thing here it's like the
people who uh end up being at the low
socioeconomic class
uh they have the hardest time like i
forget who said it but somebody said
it's really expensive to be poor in
america right that's a perfect example
like
if you're not part of that three percent
everyone else got 1200 you didn't
and it's just like yeah and they
probably don't know right which is the
uh
uh oh you what do you mean like that
three percent
don't know that they didn't get the
check because they didn't fault the
information
on the you know whatever so like that's
why they're basically reaching out to
him hey we think you may be eligible
fill out this
fill this out again education problem
education is the great equalizer
the u.s commerce department plans to
issue an
order friday that will bar people in the
united states from downloading chinese
owned messaging app
wechat and tick tock starting on
september 20th which is sunday
um again this sunday again the
trump may still approve a deal with
oracle he still hasn't said anything
but the commerce department said we're
going to be banning this starting
uh saturday or sunday if you have tick
tock download it on your phone
you can continue using it but no new app
updates
will occur and if you haven't done the
downloaded app you can't go download it
in the app store anymore
so basically they will kill tick tock in
the united states because you can't get
updates so anything that goes wrong
uh just you're done um what if
nothing ever goes wrong here's the
craziest part about this i actually
don't think that this is constitutional
uh but i think that google and apple
will comply
oh you don't think it's constitutional
for the government to tell app on google
take this app off your
store if they will hide behind it's a
national security concern
yeah uh but what ends up happening is
like
it's not right in in the sense of
this is part of the geopolitical back
and forth right
um and so what ends up happening
is uh we're going to walk a fine line
here
where companies are going to comply and
everyone's going to yell national
security
uh but this is going to if it goes to
court
i don't think that this would stand up
my guess again
guess my opinion is it looks like trump
is basically
uh putting everyone under the gun to get
a deal done so
it's got 72 hours basically to get it
done um
magically a deal might get done it's all
set i think i think it will yeah i i
just
i mean this would be insane uh tick-tock
is one thing wechat's another thing like
to go after multiple ones yeah i feel
like i feel like wechat is
massive well here's the sad part right
so forget all the geopolitics
and kind of everything uh it's the way
that a lot of um
chinese and other asian um you know kind
of countrymen
how they talk to their families like it
is
the line of communication they use it's
like like i use viper to talk to my
family involved here it's like if they
ban
that i mean we just move over to
something else but i feel like wechat is
so ingrained like
it's used for a lot of things absolutely
okay
twitter is taking steps to tighten
account security for a range of users
ahead of the us presidential election
in quite including by requiring the use
of strong passwords
why is it afraid that something's going
to happen before the election well you
just
oh high profile account sorry not just
you and me but like
yeah well there's like multiple things
right so one is they just had the hack
so like that's not good uh you know it
was a pretty immature hack like
to simply just tweet and say like hey
send bitcoin to this address
if you have the control of elon musk
bill gates
yeah all these accounts like a more
sophisticated hack would have been to
like
put a short on in the public market and
then tweet something
have everything crash and then
immediately close the shorts like you'd
make
a kill someone's thought about it well
done i thought about like if you if you
were a nefarious actor
what's the thing that you could do if
you had control of all those accounts
like that would be a really easy one
it would also be easy to get caught
because people would be able to track
but also that was a 16 year old kid or
something
of course but the point just being like
we just saw something happen
where it was like oh wait you can get
control these accounts and say all kinds
of crazy stuff
uh with an election coming up you don't
want that to happen
right so what ends up occurring is just
hey let's be proactive and let's put up
a better defense
like i i tend to think that's a smart
idea right good move by twitter
uh but it's interesting that they're
like saying it it's almost like they're
signaling to people hey it's gonna be
tougher so i don't even try
twitter twitter set accounts that will
be required to take steps to tighten
security are
the us executive branch in congress u.s
governors and secretaries of state
presidential campaigns and major u.s
news outlets and political journalists
i don't fall under any of those okay
what's next
all right so facebook is partnering with
ray-ban to make smart glasses which will
come out
next year it's not clear what features
the device will have but facebook has
confirmed that the device
will not be classified as an artificial
reality
device and it will not have an
integrated display of any kind
that suggests they may be closer to
something like snap spectacles or
perhaps
amazon echo frames i think a lot of
these companies are realizing
that uh it's hard to go from like step
one
to step 20 where all of a sudden you've
got a computer can you remember like the
google glass
right uh instead what um maybe a little
bit easier like what if we put a camera
on it right so that's like the
spectacles or the echo frames
well so you won't but no but just
privacy it's just no but just start with
like
uh creative people right so like if you
want to make a video
how cool would it be to make a video
walking around new york and you're just
filming everything through your glasses
right so you're not actually having to
carry a camera
that's like it's constantly just getting
smaller smaller smaller right
it's like there's things like that um
i absolutely believe that we're gonna go
to a world uh like the black mirror
episode
where i haven't seen it but i've heard
about it you they basically record
everything and then when you get home at
night like you can like rewind and go
back and like see stuff
our arguments would get so much more fun
that's literally one of
part of the scene is like oh she's like
show me what
like yelling at the guy but um so black
mirror might not be sci-fi look sounds
like it's more reality do we think
do we think that like facebook wants to
get in a situation with
so many privacy considerations i don't
think that there's privacy
considerations i mean there is if you're
just able to film people without them
knowing through your
glasses but i can do that with my phone
yeah but i'll see you doing that with
your phone
no you won't yes i will well how do you
know i could
i could be walking down the street
pretending to text like this
and filming it right i don't feel like
that's one two is what they do
of course there's issues but i'm just
saying like it's not as cut and dry as
just oh you can't do it or you can do it
right
uh the other thing was that um a lot of
i think it was spectacles they had like
a light
so you knew when it was on and when it
wasn't kind of like your uh
okay that's i i would be a little more
okay with that all right what's next
okay ready yeah boston dynamics
delivers its plan for logistics
robots as early as next year
so basically the company's new ceo sees
the company coming into its own after
decades of experimentation
spot will be commercialized remember
spot the dog
so basically it's gonna the dog robots
will be used for
logistics purposes yeah so what's really
interesting is that there are 75
thousand dollars like 75 000
is basically like an expensive car right
so
uh how long until this thing
can do things that you would want it to
do in your home or
you know i've seen uh robots that uh
there's this one company i knew they
created like a robotic lawn mower
so you basically kind of like a roomba
style right you just set it forget it
and it kind of figures it out
you do the same thing for your lawn and
then just goes out and mows the lawn for
you uh
there's all kinds of things that again
you can kind of see the trend of
technology
getting to the point where yeah if a
robot's seventy five thousand dollars
what happens when it's twenty thousand
dollars and it can do stuff in your home
but they're saying like as an
industrial tool seventy five thousand
dollars isn't a lot of money
but you're saying like as it becomes
more consumer focused
the price will drop well so just do the
math real quick i'm no mathematician but
he's got a calculator less than 20
million dollars to buy 260 of the 75 000
uh robots right if you're a large
manufacturing business that you know
does billions of dollars in revenue to
spend 20 million dollars
uh on a set of robots that can you know
drastically increase efficiency they're
always on
you don't have to worry about them
calling in sick like
you know it's pretty crazy yeah all
right what's next
all right um so there is a
new reality show that promises to send
the winner to space for 10 days
that's a big how did i not get on this
show it's a big promise
so it's a show called space hero and uh
the winning contestant could launch into
orbit as soon as 2023
the production company behind the
proposed series which is also called
space hero said in a press release all
right hold on a second
they're going to send a random person to
space for 10 days but you're telling me
that tom cruise isn't going to space to
fill a movie
they're saying in 2023 it could hold on
timeout it could launch in 2023. tom
cruise trying to make a movie
next year like that's a by the way two
years three years
of development on the technology to go
to space is like actually a
pretty long time yeah right if you think
about it
spacex started only 20 years ago so in
20 years
we went from not having reusable rockets
to now they're going to the iss
and shooting rockets like on a
consistent basis
so i don't know my guess is that people
are
not going to go to space they're saying
several plans to send people
to space for film or tv purposes have
fallen flat
in previous years so they're just trying
to get your attention
but i won't be watching space hero i
mean look i wouldn't do it
whatever i'm trying to go to space but
do you guys like my t-rex
we're gonna go see that october third
first yeah we're going near the
rockefeller center
all right ready for my joke bang bang
let's go okay
i'm ready um i don't think protesting
works
say why why because my whole life i've
seen
end road work signs but they keep
working on roads
what you know and road work like the end
of the road work
okay i don't think protesting works my
whole life i've seen
end road work using my job to keep
working on roads
the signs on the road okay see
part of the idea of jokes now i saw your
guys uh request for me to do
jokes so let me just quickly find one
here
the best part of this is that uh i don't
need to um
my wife told me i was immature and
needed to grow up
guess who's not allowed in my tree house
anymore
[Laughter]
i'm way better at the jokes than you are
let us know in the comments who's better
that's it for lunch money we'll see you
guys on monday
while while she's trying to get rich
russell's just trying to get a lunch
money right see you guys later
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account there's
not very many places where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends